someone who starts something and doesn't
finish something that is a loser if you
commit all that you are and all of your
energy to one thing you YouTube is in
Hollywood
I'm not Stanley Kubrick you can't
succeed here if you're uploading once a
month yeah yeah it's really crazy
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have the ability to do something
special that can change the planet so to
help you on your journey today we're
going to learn from youtuber and
filmmaker Casey nice that and my take on
his top ten rules for success volume 2
rule number one is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which one you guys
liked the best
keep your head down follow the rules do
as you're told play it safe wait your
turn ask permission learn to compromise
this is terrible advice if I was writing
an autobiography a book about right away
one title that would work with these do
what you can't because that idea
encapsulate everything I've ever done
like when I wanted to move to New York
City and my dad was like you can't you
know any money or when I first said I
wanted to make movies it was you can't
you didn't go to film school I want to
have a TV show
you can't Casey you're not pretty enough
and they characterize what this new
generation of content creators and
filmmakers what we all do on YouTube and
everywhere else is we do what we can you
don't have to listen to anyone because
in this new world no one knows anything
haters the doubters are all pretty
champagne in the top deck of the Titanic
and we are the
do what you can't that run this morning
that run in the freezing cold that was
at six o'clock this morning that is 6:00
in the a.m. I was up outside running in
the freezing cold it is currently 9 p.m.
9 o'clock at night tomorrow morning I
also have to get up at 5:30 in the
morning but I didn't shoot a vlog today
didn't shoot a video which is fine
taking days off is fine but I shot this
morning which meant I started something
so if I didn't do a vlog today it would
have meant starting something and not
finishing something and in my book
that's not OK someone who starts
something and doesn't finish something
that is a loser someone who starts
something in always finishes it that is
a closer one of my favorite movies is
called Glengarry Glen Ross here's a
quick scene a b/c they always BBC
closing always be closing always be
closing
yeah I tested that on my own last week I
talked about that Voltaire quote
perfection is the enemy of good and what
that means is you can never let your
desire for perfection prevent you from
finishing something that's good because
to finish something even imperfectly is
to learn from it and then you can move
on and get closer to perfection
now if you're an artist or a filmmaker
or content creator in general do you
feel like you shouldn't even go
mainstream towards TV or towards film or
towards working with a music label or
should you focus on creating it all
yourself because it it still helps a lot
of people who don't know how to do the
online yeah I mean look there's there's
no answer to that question I think that
it's one thing that everybody but the
successful people fail to realize about
any creative industry
that there is absolutely no defined path
there isn't one so it's about paving
your own path and now for me my path
meant mainstream just didn't work and
new media did work and for other people
it's entirely antithetical to that where
mainstream is exactly the right place
for them so there is no formula that's
that's right or wrong I'm just much
better versed in my own sure the
trajectory that I found myself and that
includes really running away from the
establishment into whatever the most
forward-thinking space is other than
hard work what advice would you give to
better yourself both in life and in your
career field focus focus is super
underrated like if you commit all that
you are and all of your energy to one
thing you'll okay this like this tire
though this is I took this from a book
called I don't know what it's called but
it goes like this alright you can do ten
things to like the first degree like
this right here and that's how well
you'll do all ten things or you can do
one thing to the tenth degree right
there and look how much better you do
that so when it comes to focus to put
all of your energy into one thing is to
do that one thing really well to the
best of your abilities to take it all
the way and to scatter yourself means
you're never actually accomplishing
anything you're just sort of chipping
away at a bunch of nothingness and this
is true for work this is true for like
dating versus committing yourself to one
person friendship everything like really
focusing and investing yourself into
something you're passionate about will
always yield better results then
scattering yourself around then
spreading yourself thin what's the best
way to find time to make films while in
high school I don't know if I got any
sympathy for you I've got a full-time
job two kids
baby wife house bills life reality and
if I can find time to make some videos
everyday then you can too I know what
high school was like I did it for like a
very short amount of time if it's
something you really want to do you will
find the time let's talk about one year
of vlogging before I started vlogging at
a YouTube channel for
five years and in those five years I had
a whole bunch of huge viral hits movies
that got like 15 16 million views
but my subscriber growth was anemic the
channel growth is anemic flat like that
five years 500,000 subscribers then I
started uploading daily and in five
months I had 500,000 more subscribers
that's 1 million subscribers five years
for the first 500,000 five months for
the second 500,000 so I kept uploading
and two months later I had another half
a million subscribers now Here I am
one year out for doing daily uploads and
I've got two and a half million
subscribers YouTube isn't Hollywood
I'm not Stanley Kubrick you can't
succeed here if you're uploading once a
month if you want to succeed here you've
got to show up for work every single day
that that took me five years to learn
I didn't start daily vlogging to grow my
youtube channel I did it as a way to
kill all of those excuses I used that
kept me from making more movies because
of every single inflection point in my
life doing the work has always been the
thing has always been the catalyst that
took me from where I am to where I want
it to be so like 10 o'clock last night I
was at the gym getting swole I was
listening to a guy named Dan Ariely
who's a behavioral economist he was
talking about why we worked and his
entire sort of thesis was predicated on
the idea that we work because we want to
not because we have to it made me think
about my YouTube channel and the fact
that I've made like 600 videos in the
last couple of years and how much I and
all the things I don't get to do in life
because I'm so focused on my work the
vast majority of the work that I do
including here on YouTube I get paid for
but it definitely is not why I show up I
get it out of this like longing or
hunger for accomplishment or this idea
of needing to complete something
professor I was listening to he equates
it to like climbing a mountain which is
a perfectly
it's an appropriate analogy because I
love climbing mountains look here is a
picture of me and my homie Graham at a
nearly 23,000 feet above sea level
my brother van put that note in there
right after we got back so why don't we
climb mountains I don't get paid to
climb mountains it's not fun do I look
too happy there I'm not happy I'm close
to death right there we climb mountains
for the same reason that we work it's
because as human beings you have this
desire to do something to complete
something how do you not give it about
what people think of you hmm I should
preface this answer by saying I
definitely got made fun of a lot for the
way that I look when I was in school and
all those bullies that picked on me are
all losers now so never forget that
people who judge others especially
people who judge others based on things
like looks on whether you're black or
white whether you're Jewish or you're
Muslim whether you are gay or straight
because of their body type whether
they're fat or skinny whether you have
pimples or whether you have a big butt
these judgmental people their opinions
don't matter because they don't matter
judgmental people are of a lower moral
authority than those who don't judge and
we people who don't judge we have a
responsibility to crush to destroy those
mean judgmental bullies and we do that
with an overwhelming positivity and we
do that with our extreme open-mindedness
and when you subscribe to those those
values you really stop caring what other
people think because chances are if
other people are judging you they're
wrong hunger is a very very powerful
motivator and when I was living in that
trailer park with the kid like we were
on welfare for a while I was a
dishwasher I worked in a crappy seafood
restaurant as a dishwasher which now
just sort of parenthetically my favorite
piece of advice to give a young people
saying I don't know what I want to do
with my life I say get a job doing
something you hate is the fastest way to
figure out what you love and where you
want to be in life is by spending a lot
of time doing something you hate so it's
miserable yeah so you know spending 50
hours a week scrubbing pots and pans was
like I was just in my head the whole
time fantasizing about what I want to do
in life as making enough to like feed my
kid and pay
you know 300 bucks and ran 300 bucks a
month rather than mortgage on my trailer
but my biggest fear was not being broke
because like when you're at rock-bottom
and you're on welfare you can still like
afford food your body yeah if I might be
a stray
like I could afford to afford my trailer
it was like we weren't homeless and
weren't starving so to me that was an
absolute destitution wasn't really like
that bad there's no dignity in it but
still it wasn't run on the streets
that's right
so with that like my it's like what is
it Laszlo's hierarchy of needs higher
needs like it's like one facing me
format basic needs were met then I
started to look around I realize like
the greatest fear for this like
beautiful little baby boy
was that he would grow up and see his
dad as a loser and that is a once those
basic needs are met that's an incredibly
powerful motivator yeah because you know
my dad who's is absolutely not a loser
but I watched my dad to provide for his
family of six I watched him work 60
hours a week hating every minute of it
and he came home from work just hating
his job and I'm feeling trapped probably
I'm sure yeah he had a family to take
care of he struggled now he does really
loves he has a coffee shop now and he's
never been happier but but I watched
that and like I just saw myself going
down that trajectory and it wasn't just
a job that I hated it was a job that I
hated that that didn't provide it was a
job that I hated that did nothing but
cover those basic needs and that was the
motivator that was when that was the
motivator the catalyst for me giving up
and moving to New York and going for it
was I still look back and I don't know
what that what that was like all right
they're only like Youth times in my life
right genuine they have no idea what I
was thinking and I moved to New York
City in June of 2001 with $800 and a
three a place to stay for three months
and that was it yeah
crazy-high yeah it's really crazy make
account was a movie about seizing the
moment grabbing life by the balls
I made that movie for Nike because
that's an idea I believe in now the
FuelBand our motivation for the movie
keeps track of how you make it count but
back when the movie was made it hadn't
been released yet I wasn't actually
wearing a fuel band but I have one now
so I thought I'd revisit the idea
I
[Music]
so what this thing does is it provides
you with a number a number that keeps
track of how active you are active can
mean a lot of things they'll give me a
budget and asking you to be active and
I'm on the next flight out air travel is
the closest thing to time travel start
in Africa always Africa we had an idea
of what we were doing but the idea was
they the only way I like to do anything
you can see two oceans from up there
that counts only flight we can find was
to Amman Jordan know this guy
motorcycles in Vietnam
jet-skiing in doha so much wind in
amsterdam we missed the train but the
adventure doesn't begin till something
goes wrong we were always moving always
the stairs never the escalator
got a car in Israel played in the mud
1,300 feet below sea level and went up
way up from 12,000 feet you fall for a
full minute that counts
I had heard about this waterfall in an
Africa
there's this great quote I don't know
who said it but it goes without a goal
you can't school
you see it's not a bungee cord it's a
static line a rope
we bought our tickets at the airport we
planned nothing because when nothing's
for sure
anything can happen
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Luke asked me to
if there's someone you'd like to vote on
for the next top 10 check out the link
in the description and go and have your
say finally you want to give a quick
shout out to Tuan from dude Buddha thank
you so much man for picking up ten
copies of my book and gifting them out
to your friends I really appreciate the
support and I'm so glad that you enjoyed
the book so thank you guys again for
watching
I believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
how I have confidence and who I am and
the decisions I make is that I have this
moral compass in life and it is like it
is a summation or an amalgam of
everything that I believe in everything
that I think is right and fair and just
and every decision that I make personal
private business every decision that I
make is made through the looking-glass
the perspective of my moral compass of
what I believe is right and what I
believe is wrong and if it's wrong I
don't make that decision I only make
decisions that I believe in and the
aggregate of that you do that over
enough time and it gives you a sense of
pride it gives you a sense of confidence
in in what you've done in life what do
you think about the comfort zone I think
it's the worst place you could ever be
when you're hungry you want more when
you're wildly successful you can embrace
your hard work and be proud of it when
you're in the comfort zone it's just
what's the key to being successful on
YouTube are creating content online
right now is it having the nice fancy
camera is it's the production value is
it's an oddity it's look if I could if I
could define what it took I think a lot
more people would follow that trajectory
that's the greatest job in the world but
so I don't know what's right but I can
definitely tell you what it's not and
what if not is having the best gear
first of all you know if the vlog that I
posted this morning which is I posted
only five hours ago and it's really I'm
looking at my cell phone right now to
figure out to tell you guys exactly how
many views it's done in the last couple
is it on the phone like a city in West
but what the key is not is is the gear
and I think that's what's what's so
limiting for people when they think I've
got to have the right gear the right
that's the wrong like my HBO show was
shot on a point-and-shoot that we bought
at Walmart rune but I mean so much of my
youtube one of my most watched videos on
YouTube called bike lanes which is over
15 million views that was shot on the
crappiest a point-and-shoot cameras yeah
just so it's not it's it's it's what you
do with the tools not what the tools are
themselves
so I'm just looking at my stats right
here so my video that I posted this
morning so I posted it 3 hours and 58
minutes ago and it has a hundred and
forty thousand views on YouTube yeah in
the last three hours around this video
primarily was shot on my cell phone
Wow because iPhone 6 because MTV didn't
allow any cameras at the VMAs but they
did like allow cell phones so I'm like
standing there being like you guys
realize that every cell phone is a video
camera built in how ridiculously cons to
country all this means is that there's
me a million bad videos posted instead
of a million videos but regardless like
you know half that video was shot on my
cell phone yeah and it's just not it's
like if you can do great things with a
terrible camera you can do great things
with a great camera